Okay, so we are leaving the United States
of America and we are going international.
And the first place we are going to visit
is Europe. So we're now going to look at
our ninth leading indicator, the European
Economic Sentiment Indicator, or sometimes
referred to as the ESI.
But first, let's have a look at what we've
looked at so far and where we are going
with the direction of the PTM video
series. So instead of naming this slide
now, what we have covered so far, what
we're actually doing is formatting an
entire leading indicator dashboard. So you
can see on the left hand side, everything
we've covered,
so far, and everything on the right hand
side, where we're going with our leading
indicators now. So on the left hand side,
we have our US leading indicators. And on
the right hand side, we have our
international leading indicators. So
starting with the US leading indicators,
we have our money markets indicators, we
have our surveys, and we have our cyclical
commodity prices. On the right hand side,
we have our international
leading indicators. And we have our
digital leading indicators. And we have
our digital leading indicators. And you
can see in money markets, for example, if
you go to the downloads area in video
number four, you'll be able to get the
interest rate data and analysis. So you
can do similar money market analysis, as
we did in the United States for several
other countries. So for Japan, UK,
Germany,
and Italy. And Italy. And also you will
find Chinese real interest rate data. And
what we're going to be doing in the next
video is covering China. So we will be
covering China in the next video in
surveys. We will also be covering in the
next video, the China manufacturing PMI.
So at the end of the time, you should seek
out further education on market PMIs.
Markit is a company that puts together PMI
data for countries all over the world. To
add into your analysis of what we cover in
the PTM video series, market PMIs for
Japan, UK, Brazil, and Canada will be
prudent to cover. But of course, you can
do research
and do monthly updates on all countries if
you want to. What we're doing here in the
PTM is covering all of the main ones.
Additionally, in international cyclical
commodity prices, you can see from the
downloads area for cyclical commodities
prices in that video. In the files, you do
get the international front month futures
contracts for cyclical commodities that
are
international, which are not
international, such as Brent oil, LME,
London metal exchange copper, and for
Shanghai copper. So as traders and PMs, we
now have a pretty comprehensive dashboard
of macroeconomic leading indicators, both
in the US and internationally, to help us
survey the picture at any one time, any
one moment in time, the macroeconomic
picture in the
United States and the United States and
internationally. But right now, what we're
going to be doing is looking at the
European Economic Sentiment Indicator and
building out our international analysis.
In the downloads area for this video, you
will see the file European Economic
Sentiment Indicator. And in the downloads
areas for videos three and four, you'll
find global GDP. And you'll
find the benchmark yields EU files, and
they will be important for understanding
the content of this video. Now, before we
get into the European Economic Sentiment
Indicator, the ESI, we have to understand
some important stuff about Europe, and
specifically European GDP, and how it fits
into the global picture.
There are two ways of defining Europe.
There's the European Union and the
Eurozone. And we're going to be
specifically looking at the Eurozone. And
there's 19 member states of the Eurozone.
So those are the countries that are
members of the common currency, the Euro.
And this is considered a single economic
area. Now, when we look
the size of the size of the Eurozone
economy, the Eurozone is 62.2% the size of
the United States and 90% the size of
China. And if you look on the left-hand
side, the Eurozone is made up of the 19
states on the left-hand side with the GDP
stats for 2019. And at the bottom of the
table, you can see the total Eurozone GDP.
the GDP number for 2019. Now, in 2019,
global GDP was 87.345 trillion US dollars.
And the US, so US GDP was 24.5% of that
number. China was 16.8% of global GDP in
2019. And the Eurozone, in total, was
15.2% of that number.
in 2019. Now, if we add the US, China and
the Eurozone GDP together in 2019, we get
to a figure of 49.5 trillion US dollars.
And that's equivalent to 56.5% of global
GDP. So you can see that Eurozone is
obviously a very important economic area.
And as traders and PMs,
we have to try and predict constantly U.S.
GDP. So growth, so direction and growth.
And we also have to do the same for the
Eurozone and China, or at least make a
very good attempt at doing so. By doing
so, we not only get the macroeconomic
picture in the US, but we also get the
macroeconomic picture internationally. So
we can build
a global macroeconomic. Now, a global
macroeconomic view. Now, in terms of
context, again, if we look at Europe
versus a list of the top countries in the
world by nominal GDP in 2019, we can look
at the Eurozone in comparison to GDP of
every country. And actually, the
constituents of Europe as well.
So if we actually added up all the
constituents of Europe, and if we ranked
the Eurozone 19 countries as one economic
area, it would actually be the third
largest economic zone in the world. And
its nearest competitor, Japan, the
Eurozone is actually 2.62 times larger
than the Japanese economy.
based on 2019 numbers. So it's obviously
vitally important that we understand the
Eurozone economy based on 2019 numbers. So
it's obviously vitally important that we
understand the Eurozone economy and
predict European GDP growth. By doing so,
we can achieve the same results as we do
by staying on top of U.S. leading
indicators. We can predict European GDP
growth and get a better picture of global
rest of world GDP growth.
outside the U.S. outside the U.S., which
in turn, actually affects U.S. GDP growth
and vice versa. And of course, this will
end up affecting our portfolio bias in the
U.S. So whether we're looking to be long,
short, or neutral in our portfolios.
Additionally, we'll see you next to the
U.S. Additionally, we'll see you next
time.
We'll see you next time.
All of the countries that make up the
Eurozone. We treat them as two separate
entities as traders and PMs. And we focus
on the Eurozone. And you can see also in
the table, the actual European Economic
Sentiment Indicator, ESI codes for each
country. So we split out the Eurozone from
the European Union and only analyze those
countries as a collective that use the
Euro as their common code.
and that are mandated by the ECB. Members
of the European Union that are not in the
Eurozone actually have their own currency.
So, for example, Poland has the Zloty,
Hungary has the Forint, and Romania has
the Loo.
Now, although these countries do have
close trade relationships with the other
European Union states,
they actually maintain their own
independent central banks and monetary
policy that is separate from the European
Central Bank.
However, the central banks of those
countries are part of the European system
of central banks, the ESCB,
which is required to meet convergence
criteria with a view to eventually joining
the Eurozone.
Now, just as a side note, as of the time
of filming, the UK is in the process of
leaving the European Union.
However, it is still part of the ESI
European Union data.
So it's part of the ESI European Union
stats as of January 2021.
And this is probably going to change in
the future.
So you may want to update your
spreadsheets properly when that happens.
So just keep an eye out for that.
So we get a much better understanding of
European GDP growth outlook by focusing on
the Eurozone,
the harmonized common currency and
monetary policy block of the Eurozone
itself.
Now, let's get into the data of the
Eurozone and have a look at the Eurozone
stocks 600.
So the European benchmark index versus
Eurozone GDP growth.
And if you go to the downloads area of
video number three, I mentioned earlier,
the sheet global GDP.
If you download that and scan the sheets
at the bottom of the file, you'll see
files that relate to the Eurozone and the
Eurozone stock 600 versus GDP growth.
And specifically, what we're doing here is
the quadnominal analysis that we did
earlier with the S&P 500 and U.S. GDP
growth.
So similar to the way in which we analyzed
that, so in which we analyzed U.S. GDP
direction and S&P 500 direction, we can
analyze Eurozone GDP and the European
benchmark index, the Euro stocks 600.
All of the data, all of the data, all of
the data is in the spreadsheets that are
available in the downloads area of video
number three, where we did the GDP
quadnomial analysis and correlations for
benchmark indices and GDP growth in the
major economic areas of the world.
Now, for the sake of repetition in this
video series, we're not going to go
through the explanation of exactly how we
put together the whole quadnomial
analysis, we went through the quadnomial
analysis and correlations with S&P 500 and
U.S. GDP.
And did this for Eurozone and China as
well in video number three.
So if you need a reminder of how all this
is put together and how it all works, just
go back to video number three, rewatch
that and relearn the information at a good
pace.
You'll start to understand it and you'll
get it eventually.
So, let's have a look at the actual
outcome of the stats for the Stocks 600
leading Eurozone GDP.
So, if you remember, we have our four
cases, we have our 0-0, our 1-1, our 0-1
and our 1-0 outcomes for the direction of
the index,
which in this case is the Stocks 600 and
GDP growth, which is in this case,
Eurozone GDP growth.
And if you look in the spreadsheet, you'll
see that the data in this case for the
Eurozone only goes back to 1995, and we
have a total of 101 cases.
So, that is 101 quarters.
So, about 25 years.
Now, if you look at the table there, you
can see the cases of 0-0 and 1-1.
They are marked in yellow on the left-hand
side, and you can see 0-1 and 1-0 marked
in green.
Now, the 0-0 and 1-1 situation is
basically when the index and GDP growth
move in the same direction.
So, 0-0, the index goes down in the
quarter, and then GDP is reported down.
So, that's the 0-0 case.
And the 1-1 case is the index going up in
the quarter from the previous quarter, and
GDP is reported up.
And if you look at the AB scenarios, the
0-0 and the 1-1, we have 64 cases out of
101 cases.
So, 64 quarters out of 101 quarters that
the stocks 600 goes up and Eurozone GDP is
reported up.
So, this is 63.37% of times.
And then, with the 0-0 case, where the
Eurostox 600 goes down and Eurozone GDP
goes down, this happens nine quarters out
of our 101 cases.
So, historically, GDP is moving in the
same direction as the index.
So, Eurozone GDP is moving in the same
direction as the stocks 600, 72.28% of
quarters.
Now, what happens in the cases when it
doesn't?
So, when the stock 600 doesn't go in the
same direction as GDP, or GDP is reported
in a different direction to the direction
of the stocks 600.
Well, when it doesn't go in the same
direction, the majority of the time, it's
because the stock 600 moves down when GDP
goes up.
So, we have a 0-1 situation.
And this happens 23 cases out of 101
cases.
So, for 23 quarters out of our 101 quarter
data set, which basically is 22.77% of
times.
And we attribute this to the market
getting ahead of itself.
And then, for a quarter, it goes down when
GDP growth is reported up.
So, this can't be explained by
fundamentals.
This is more of a technical situation in
one of those specific quarters.
So, we attribute this to profit taking.
Now, in the other scenario where stock 600
and Eurozone GDP don't move in the same
direction.
This is the 1-0 scenario, when for the
quarter, the stock 600 goes up and GDP is
reported down.
This is in the vast minority of cases.
This happens less than 5% of times.
So, we only have five quarters out of our
entire data set of 101 quarters since
1995, where the stock 600 has moved up and
GDP has actually gone down or is reported
down in the quarter after the move.
So, we have roughly 72% of times the stock
600 and Eurozone GDP moving in the same
direction, reported in the same direction.
And roughly 28% of times, moving in the
opposite direction.
However, we know that the vast majority of
times, when they don't move together, we
get the 0-1 situation.
We get the profit taking or technical
outcome.
So, if we can predict GDP fundamentally
and take profits at the right times,
technically, we can be right 95% of the
time when predicting the stocks 600 move
leading Eurozone GDP.
Now, we can see this data borne out
visually on a chart of the stocks 600
year-on-year percentage change versus
Eurozone GDP year-on-year percentage
change.
So, if you think of our majority of cases,
which is the 1-1 scenario, where we have
Euro-Stock 600 positive for the quarter
and Eurozone GDP positive for the quarter,
you can see above the 0 bound, you can see
that for the majority of cases, they are
both moving in the same direction and that
is positive.
What we can also note visually is our
other scenario when they both move in the
same direction, which is the 0-0 scenario.
So, most notably, in the periods of the
global financial crisis, where you see the
stock 600 year-on-year percentage
performance leading negative GDP growth in
2008.
And then also, in the 2011 period, where
we see the stock 600 year-on-year
percentage again leading negative GDP
growth.
And we can also see our other scenario,
which is a period of quarter when the
stocks 600 is reported down and Eurozone
GDP is reported up.
So, this is our 0-1 scenario.
And most notably, you can see this
occurring on several occasions in the 2015
to 2019 period.
So, if you look at the chart, you'll see
the stock 600 year-on-year percentage
reported several times as negative.
And in the same quarter, you'll see
Eurozone GDP reported as positive.
And if you look at the preceding period,
which is the 2012 to 2015 period, you'll
see that the Eurozone GDP number is going
positive.
And there's multiple readings of the stock
600 having very positive year-on-year
percentage moves of between 10% and 15%.
So, the preceding period, this is where
there was obviously a lot of stimulus in
Europe from the ECB.
And then the index, the stock 600, even
though GDP was reported as positive for
that period, 2015 to 2019, the index
struggled on occasions to keep up with GDP
growth and put in year-on-year positive
percentage returns.
So, this has actually had the effect of
breaking down the correlation of the stock
600 versus Eurozone GDP growth.
If you recall, we had our chart in the
global GDP file for each economic area.
So, the US, Eurozone and China for rolling
correlation.
And for the stock 600 and Eurozone GDP
growth, we were looking at a five-year
correlation with a six-month lag because
the six-month lag on a five-year
correlation basis gave us the highest
correlation.
So, the read across here is that in our
data set up until around 2015, this is
when we had a very decent, strong
correlation on a six-month rolling
five-year average.
And from 2015 onwards, this correlation
started to break down.
And you can see from the previous chart,
it's down to the index not putting in a
positive performance when GDP is reported
at the end of each quarter as positive.
You can see that visually on the previous
chart, so we get multiple 0-1 outcomes.
And as mentioned, this is most probably
down to monetary policy from the ECB.
And in the period 2011 to 2015, the
stimulus provided by the ECB, so low
interest rates and massive bond purchase
programs, the stimulus worked quite well
for the returns of the stocks 600.
But from 2015 onwards, low interest rates
or even negative real interest rates and
bond purchase programs have had much less
of an impact on stock 600 year-on-year
percentage returns.
Now, this doesn't mean as traders and
portfolio managers that we discount this
analysis and we ignore it.
Of course, we stay on top of these things.
And for the entire history, it's true that
the majority of times that the Eurostox
600 and Eurozone GDP for a good 20 years
for the majority of times moved in the
same direction.
We've had in the last five years a
breakdown of this correlation.
But of course, that can change in the
future.
And as traders and PMs, we have to stay on
top of these things, not least because it
gives us a global macro picture, a global
macro overview of what's occurring in
economies and stock markets.
But also because we can actually get a lot
of trade ideas from this situation itself.
Now, how does the ESI, the European
Economic Sentiment Indicator, fit into all
of this?
Well, the European Commission publishes
all of the main leading indicators for
Europe in one monthly report.
So if you imagine what we've done so far
in the PTM video series, when we've been
looking at US leading indicators, they are
all published separately.
And in Europe, it works differently.
The European Commission publishes all of
the leading indicators for Europe in one
monthly report.
And that is the European Economic
Sentiment Indicator.
The numbers are released on the last
business day of the month for the same
month, which basically makes the report a
very timely leading indicator for
forecasting European GDP growth.
It's a huge, massive report.
And from a trader's process perspective,
it requires a lot of organization to build
the initial spreadsheets and to maintain
them on a regular basis because it
includes all leading indicators for every
single country in Europe.
Now, the link there on the screen, that's
where the ESI reports can be found each
month and also all of the data on a
monthly basis and historical data that you
need to build and maintain your monthly
spreadsheets.
Fortunately, if you go to the downloads
area of this video, you will find the
downloads called European Economic
Sentiment Indicator.
And we've done all of the initial work for
you.
So all of the hard yards have been done in
collecting all the data and organizing it
properly for you in the downloads area.
It's up to you on a monthly basis to
update and maintain that spreadsheet.
Now, how does the ESI actually work?
What's the survey design?
Well, each country has the same five
component surveys that make up the
composite index for that particular
country.
So what that does for us as traders and
PMs, it makes absolute and relative
measures possible when we're looking at a
country individually and countries
compared to each other.
And you can see the five component surveys
that make up the composite number for each
country in the table on the screen.
So we have the highest weighting, which is
the industrial confidence indicator, which
is weighted as 40%.
So basically these are like the equivalent
in the US to the ISM Manufacturing Survey
and the ISM Non-Manufacturing or Services
Survey.
We also have the equivalent in Europe of
our UMCSI, our Consumer Sentiment Index.
The Consumer Confidence Indicator in
Europe makes up 20% of the ESI.
We also have in Europe retail trade
confidence indicator, which is 5%
weighting.
And the construction confidence indicator,
which is the equivalent of our building
permits or housing slots in the US.
We have our construction confidence
indicator that comes in at 5%.
So taken all together, this makes up the
overall economic sentiment indicator for
both European Union and the Eurozone area.
Now, the way the data is collected and
organized by the European Commission, the
subcomponents for each country are
measured as the difference between the
percentages of respondents giving positive
and negative replies in each of the
surveys.
And then the composite EU and Eurozone
area indices are indexed to 100.
And the ESI composite for each country and
the EU and EA aggregates are scaled to a
long-term mean of 100 and a standard
deviation of 10.
So the way to look at this is values above
100 indicates above average economic
sentiment and values below 100 indicates
below average economic sentiment.
And we can see all of this data visually
in the downloads area in the charts that
we've constructed.
So remember, we are looking at the
Eurozone, so the European area economic
sentiment indicator, not the whole
European Union.
So we're looking at the Eurozone 19 member
states as part of the Euro common
currency.
And if you look at the chart here on the
left-hand side, we have our ESI scale and
you can see the 100 level.
And that is set as the long-term mean.
So you can see we've added in, in the red
line, a long-term trend line average,
which is the 100 level.
And if you recall, plus 10 and minus 10
points on this index is a one standard
deviation move.
So anything outside of that is either
greater than a one standard deviation move
in the positive or a one standard
deviation move in the negative.
And you can see periods, obviously, where
we have a positive sentiment in the
European economic area, so the Eurozone.
And you can see periods of negative
sentiment.
And we can look through a few of these.
So for example, in recent history, where
we have the COVID shutdown, COVID economic
shutdown, you can see we get extreme
negative sentiment in the periods that we
looked at earlier.
So the 2015 to 2019 period, when we saw
our correlations breaking down between the
Eurostox 600 and Eurozone GDP growth, we
actually have very positive sentiment
during that period.
This didn't translate into positive
Eurostox 600 year-on-year percentage
returns for the whole period, only for
some of the period, but there were also
negative periods as well.
And we also have the 2011 to 2015 period
that we looked at earlier, and we can see
here that there's some mildly bearish
sentiment or negative sentiment occurring
during this period.
And correlations were still fairly high at
this time between the Eurostox 600 and
Eurozone GDP growth.
And we actually had during that time, if
you recall, we had fairly solid Eurostox
600 year-on-year percentage returns and
positive GDP growth as well during that
period.
Now we can have a look at these periods in
more detail by looking at the
sub-components and see where the bullish
and bearish sentiment was actually coming
from.
But also, if you go a little bit further
back in history on the composite number
here, you can see, for example, bearish
sentiment occurring before the global
financial crisis in 2008, 2009.
So yes, you can see the extreme move
negative at the end of 2008 and beginning
of 2009.
But we do see Eurozone sentiment at the
composite level peaking in 2007 and
managing a fairly rapid decline into
bearish sentiment at the beginning to mid
of 2007.
And this is worth taking note of because
the ESI and in particular, the one we're
looking at now, which is the most
important, the Eurozone area, like our US
leading indicators, we do get peaks and
drops.
So you remember that 10 points in the
positive and negative are one standard
deviation and when we get our extreme
moves like a 2 or 3 standard deviation
move, for example, in the negatives, we
can see they become troughs.
And then in the positives when we have
outside one standard deviation moves.
Yes, the ESI can stay there for a while,
but it tends to peak above the one around
the 115 or above the 115 level.
Now, for each of our subcomponents, we can
look at their contribution or what they
were doing at the time in certain periods
of economic cycles and their contribution
to the composite index.
So if we look at the industrial confidence
index here, which is one of the
subcomponents, remember it's 40%
weighting, this is the equivalent to a
manufacturing PMI.
So if we look at that, for example, in the
period 2015 to 2019, you can see its
negative sentiment for half of that period
and positive for the remainder of that
period.
So this was contributing positively in the
latter part of the 2015-2019 period to
that positive composite data.
So manufacturing companies were actually
quite bullish.
And in the 2011 to 2015 period, there's a
negative sentiment here.
And obviously, they were contributing to
that negative number at the composite
level as well.
Now, a couple of things to note here.
If you look at the scale on the left-hand
side, you'll see the zero band level and
you'll see a positive 10.
In the upper scale and negative 10,
negative 20 and negative 30.
And you'll notice that we haven't included
positive 20 and positive 30 on the
positive scale because that's because
there haven't been any readings that high
since data began in 1985 for the
industrial confidence indicator.
And remember, this is the difference in
percentages of respondents giving a
positive sentiment and a negative
sentiment on the month.
And if you look at that long term trend
line, the red trend line, the long term
average here is in the negative.
So what do we deduce from this?
On average, European manufacturing
businesses are always bearish.
We can see this type of data borne out in
the service sector.
So remember, this component is a 30%
weighting in the index.
And we can see that for the most part,
services over the entire data set, for the
most part, have been in the positive.
However, the long term average has been
coming down the entire time from positive
and even went negative in the late teens.
So in 2019.
So the service sector of the economy has
been in the vast majority positive and the
manufacturing in the majority negative.
However, services sentiment on average
keeps going lower when we look at it over
multiple years.
So that's the red average long term trend
line on the screen.
So yes, in the bigger picture, services in
Europe have been replacing manufacturing
as a core part of the economy.
And yes, there's been overall bullish
sentiment in services over the last 35
years or so.
And manufacturing has been bearish.
So we can read a lot into the European
project here in terms of sentiments coming
from the manufacturing side of the
Eurozone economy over the last 35 years.
And the services side of the economy over
the last 35 years.
And if we think of those, that period
split up into two periods in the previous
decade.
So around the 2011 to 2019, 20 period.
And we split that up down the middle at
the composite level.
If you recall, we had a negative period at
the composite level 2011 onwards.
And we had a positive period from 2015 to
2019 at the composite level.
Well, the services sector was negative
during the negative time.
So the tail end of 2011 to around the 2014
period.
And then 2015, that's when we have a
positive contribution for a long time from
the services sector.
So services were definitely contributing
positively to the positive time and
negative to the negative time at the
composite level.
So certainly during that 2014 to 2017
period, when the manufacturing sector was
reporting bearish sentiment and
contributing bearish to the composite
number, the service sector was
contributing positively.
So the service sector was kind of bailing
out the manufacturing sector at that time.
Now let's talk about the European
consumer, which I always find a little bit
entertaining to have a look at this data
and have a look at this chart.
Remember the scale is the difference
between, in the survey, the difference
between positive responses and negative
responses.
And if you look at the screen here for the
Eurozone consumer, they're always
negative.
There hasn't been a positive reading where
European consumers have been positive in
the last 35 years.
The long term trend line is negative and
the best we're ever going to get from
these guys is peaks that are negative.
So peaks in the consumer sentiment are
actually still negative.
Now this may have something to do with the
long term unemployment rates or youth
unemployment in the Eurozone area, but
it's likely that it's cultural as well.
In that European consumers are more
bearish on average than US consumers,
which are much more cyclical.
And it may also be to do with the long
term unemployment rates and credit that's
available to the consumer and also the
propensity to take on more consumer credit
in the Eurozone area.
But whether it's down to long term
unemployment rates or very high youth
unemployment rates or it's cultural or a
combination of both, there's no denying
what's on the screen.
The European consumer, the European
consumer, Eurozone consumer is just always
bearish.
And it's just a question of how bearish or
bullish they are.
And the best case when they're bullish is
that they're still bearish.
So try to figure that one out.
But if you think of our periods that we
looked at in the last decade, so 2011 to
2015 and then 2015 to 2019, 2020, you can
see in the 2011 period to around 2014, you
can see that the European consumer was
just huge.
The European consumer was just very
bearish.
And when you think of the 2015 period to
2019, 2020 period, they were contributing
negatively less to the overall number at
the composite level.
Therefore, it can be argued that, you
know, on a relative basis throughout
history, they were actually fairly
positive because they're above the long
term average trend line, which is the red
line on the screen.
So probably the best way to think of this
and even to memorize and remember what
this number is all about in terms of the
European consumer, just look at it as kind
of like a misery index.
Overall, the European consumer is just
miserable all the time.
It's just a question of how miserable they
actually are.
Now, if we look at the retail sector, so
we have a look at retail sentiment, you
can see a similar situation here where
when you look at the responses in the
survey, whether they're in the positive or
the negative for the entire period, up
until the 2014, 2015 period,
we only have some very, very small
localized moments in history where the
retail sector in Europe reported net
positive sentiment.
And in the current period that we've
analyzed in the 2015 to 2019 period, you
can see during that period that the retail
sector was obviously reporting throughout
its entire history, the longest and most
positive periods of sentiment.
So you can see just visually that for the
vast majority of times over the last 35
years, we get negative readings.
This is borne out by the long term average
trend line that you can see in red.
So basically, it has been improving, but
it's just on average in the negative all
the time.
And yes, it has been getting better, but
it's taken on average to go 35 years from
negative 10 to around negative 5.
So maybe in 35 years time, we might see
the retail sector in Europe in the
Eurozone actually have an average positive
sentiment.
But I very much doubt it.
And if you think of the consumer sentiment
data that we looked at on the previous
slide, that's extremely unlikely to
happen.
And just to give you an idea, you know, of
how generally bearish sentiment is in the
European retail sector.
If you think of the period 2002 to 2007,
when we had one of the biggest economic
booms ever in the history of capitalism in
the world.
And the European retail sector for the
vast majority of that time period was
reporting bearish sentiment.
So if that's not going to get the
patient's heart moving again, beating
again, then probably nothing ever will.
If you think of our periods that we looked
at, the 2015 to 2019 period, if you think
of the 2011 to 2015 period,
although this has a 5% weighting, so very
small contribution to the composite
number, you can see for most of that
period,
there was pretty extreme bearish sentiment
occurring in the European retail sector.
Next up is our construction sector.
And again, mostly in the negative for the
entire 35 or so year data set history,
only on a few occasions.
So in our period that we've been looking
at the 2015 to 2019 period, you can see
from 2017 to 2019, you can see that
there's a positive period.
And we also get a positive period in
construction in the tail end of the boom
before the financial crisis in 2009.
So we get that construction positive
sentiment, 2006, 2007.
We get small blips in the early 2000s in
positive.
And in the late 80s, we get a small blip
positive as well.
But for the vast, vast majority of
situations in history, the survey
respondents are pretty much for the entire
history bearish.
And for this sector, it's yes, again, a
low weighting 5% contribution to the
composite index.
But it's important to understand and
understand some economic history here.
So when we're moving forward, we can
understand what is going on in the
construction sector and in the economy as
a whole.
If you look back to the recovery period
after the global financial crisis, look at
the extreme bearishness that occurred in
2009.
So we're looking at around 35%, 36%, 37%
negative in the response differences
between positive and negative sentiment.
And look at the recovery in the
construction sector.
It doesn't recover at all until nine years
later.
So we're looking at positive sentiment
occurring around the end of 2017,
beginning of 2018.
And you can see that there's negative
sentiment to negative 20, pretty much all
the way up to the end of 2015.
So when you put this into context of what
was happening from the ECB, the massive
amounts of stimulus, low interest rates,
negative interest rates, negative real
interest rates, massive bond buying
programs during that entire period.
And the Eurozone construction sector
stayed bearish the whole time.
So when you think about this, again, the
construction sector, like the Eurozone
retail sector, and even the Eurozone
consumer, when you think of this in the
context of what's happened over the last
decade, the question is, is what, if
anything, is ever going to get the
patient's heart beating again?
When you think of it in the context of all
the stimulus that's happened, the answer
is, probably nothing ever will.
So when you think of that ESI composite
number and the weightings of the five
components, it's obviously far more
important from a trader and portfolio
management perspective to look at the
contribution of the manufacturing sector
and whether there's bullish or bearish
sentiment there.
And the contribution to the composite
index.
And also look at the services sector and
the service sector contribution and
whether the manufacturing sector and
service sector are both contributing
positively, both contributing negatively,
or they're butting heads where one is
contributing positively and one is
contributing negatively.
So remember, the weightings of the
manufacturing sector is 40% contribution
to the composite index, and the services
sector is 30%.
So from a trader's and portfolio manager's
perspective, when we're seeking to
forecast potential GDP growth direction
and Euro stocks 600 returns in the bigger
picture, we need to focus, obviously, a
lot more on the manufacturing sector and
service sector PMIs that are part of the
overall composite index.
And then, of course, we have the consumer,
Eurozone consumer, we have the Eurozone
retail sector, and we have the Eurozone
construction sector.
Eurozone consumer is 20% weighting, and
retail is 5% and construction is 5%, so
much lower weightings, so a combined 30%.
But, remember, they're always bearish.
But remember, they're always bearish.
It's just a question of how bearish they
are.
So from a trader and portfolio manager
perspective, yes, we have to pay some
attention, of course, to the consumer from
a macroeconomic perspective.
But from a macro perspective, we're not
putting anywhere near as much emphasis on
the European retail sector and the
European construction sector as the
contribution of manufacturing and services
to the overall number.
And also, remember, because they're just
always bearish.
It's just a question of how bearish they
are.
But we don't never, ever, of course, not
pay attention to it.
If they are less bearish or extreme
bearish, this can mean important stuff for
our macro outlook, but much more so for
our trade ideas that we can get from the
retail sector and the construction sector
in Europe.
Now, if you recall, each country within
the Eurozone, and even for the European
Union data, each country has its own ESI
and also reports its own five components.
Now, we've put these all in alphabetical
order.
Obviously, the size of the economies is
more important to consider in terms of the
read across for traders and PMs for GDP
growth and potential Euro stock 600
returns and even for trade ideas.
So, obviously, the size of the economy is
more important, but we're going to go
through on the screens here all of them.
We won't spend as much time on the smaller
ones, sometimes no time, but we'll focus
more on the bigger economies.
But you can get this data in the ESI, and
this is something you should update every
month because it's very useful to get an
overall picture of the macroeconomics and
also what is happening locally in each
country within Europe,
not least because you can actually
generate some trade ideas from them.
So, let's start going through these.
On the screen, you can see Austria.
Now, obviously, Austria, it's a very small
economy in the global context.
So, we don't pay much attention to the
contribution that these countries make to
the overall Eurozone.
But we obviously do pay attention and
update our data in the spreadsheets
monthly from a trade idea generation
perspective.
The way you should look at all of these,
and this is even the small economies,
okay, the way you should look at all of
these is just eyeball them.
So, when you're in the downloads area and
you download the spreadsheets and you're
updating it every month, you'll update
these charts.
And if you just eyeball them and look at
each area, so the five contributors, and
when you eyeball them, just look for some
basic things.
Understand the long-term trend, understand
the long-term trend, look at the red
lines, so the long-term average trend
lines, and where we are at the time, below
trend or above trend, and fit it into the
bigger picture.
So, Austria, small economy, we don't pay
much attention to it.
much attention to it, but we update the
data, we do it diligently, and perhaps one
day, we may have a trade idea in these
smaller economies, but we just think of
the longer-term trend, and whether we're
above trend or below trend, and what it
means in the bigger picture at any one
moment in time.
Belgium, again, very, very small economy,
we don't spend too much time on it, we
just update the data.
Cyprus, obviously ridiculously small.
Estonia, very small, irrelevant.
Finland, small as well.
And then we get to one of our big
economies, France.
France, obviously a very big economy in
the Eurozone, meaningful for the world, so
we pay attention to it.
If you recall back to previous slides
where we had the GDP tables, in 2019,
you'll notice that in US dollars, the
French economy was 2.7 trillion US
dollars, which ranked it the seventh
largest economy in the world.
So, you can see here, if we start
eyeballing France, and start paying
attention to some of the long-term trends,
and the details of recent history.
So, if you look at the ESI, for example,
on the top left-hand corner of the screen,
you'll see for France, coming out of the
global financial crisis, we had a strong
recovery from the global financial crisis
in 2008-2009, where you see that strong
recovery above average trend in 2010.
And then 2011, it goes back below the 100
level, and below the long-term average
trend line.
And it takes a very long time afterwards
for the French economy to recover the
overall ESI, the sentiment of the French
economy.
And if you look at the contributing
factors, if we look down in the bottom
left, we can see the manufacturing sector,
French manufacturing sector, and post the
positive surge after, in sentiment, after
the global financial crisis, we get French
manufacturing 2010-11 going below the 100
level.
And then it takes all the way up to
basically 2016-17 to get back into
positive sentiment again.
And then in 2018, it goes negative.
Overall, you can see the long-term average
trend line for French manufacturing is
below zero.
So just above, below negative 10.
And yeah, it's a pretty horizontal slope
for the entire data set.
So French manufacturing on average over
the entire data set of around 35 years is
average bearish.
And you can see it's borne out in the data
in the charts.
You can see over time, over the last 35
years, there's just way more negative data
points in terms of sentiment versus
positive.
And again, think of that period, the 2011
to 2019 period, and think of the context,
especially in the 2011 to 2015, 2016
period.
Think of the context of all of the ECB
activity and policy of negative real rates
and huge bond buying, bond purchase
programs.
And again, what's going to get the
heartbeat of the patient actually beating
again?
Well, it took a hell of a lot just to get
positive sentiment in the French
manufacturing sector post the financial
crisis.
And then it didn't last long.
If we look at the French service sector,
so in the top middle portion of the
screen, you'll see a similar situation,
but we're actually moving from positive to
negative.
So positive sentiment to negative
sentiment on average over 35 years.
You can see coming out of the financial
crisis, there was a very sharp recovery in
the French services sector, but it didn't
last long.
And then we went into that low period of
2011 to 2015, 2016.
And then we had a positive period, 16 to
20, and then went negative again.
But overall, taking notes of the long term
average trend line, you can see that the
long term average trend for French
services reported as negative sentiment
has been decreasing overall, on average,
over 35 years.
Moving on to the French consumer, overall,
long term average trend bearish, apart
from a few positive blips in the late
1990s.
In the late 1990s, early 2000s, all the
data is negative.
And it's actually getting worse.
The line is sloping left to right and
getting lower.
So the red long term moving average is
sloping down.
And there's only one way to sum this up,
guys.
The French consumer is just miserable
pretty much all the time.
It's just a question of how miserable they
are.
Moving on to the retail sector in France.
So top right of the screen, you can see
that in the 90s, there was some occasional
blips positive.
In the mid 2000s, we get the longest
period ever of French retailers being
bullish in terms of sentiment.
We crash in terms of sentiment in the
retail sector in the global financial
crisis.
That's to be completely expected.
And then for the rest of the data set,
just occasional blips that are positive
bullish sentiment.
Overall, just again, like consumers in
France, the French retail sector is just a
pretty dire sight to behold.
Moving on to the construction sector, the
most positive periods in history were in
the late 90s and early to mid 2000s before
the financial crisis.
After the GFC, the construction sector in
France didn't recover till end of 2017,
beginning of 2018 in terms of sentiment.
And we had about a year and a half, two
years of positive sentiment before the
COVID collapse.
So yeah, long term average trend for the
French construction sector, bearish
sentiment.
So not looking good again.
So French construction, yes, it's
positively sloping, but it's always
negative in the average.
So again, we pay more attention to the
larger economies like France.
And obviously they're having a much bigger
impact on the ESI and the global economy
due to the size of the economy.
So we pay more attention to them.
Next up, Germany, which is biggest economy
in Europe.
So Germany, if you recall from the tables
earlier in the slides, Germany is the
fourth largest economy in the world.
And in 2019 was 3.8 trillion US dollars
equivalent in GDP.
Germany, if you look in the top left and
have a look at the German ESI number going
into and out of the financial crisis and
think about it in the context of France,
the recovery was quicker and sharper in
Germany and actually more sustained
overall than in France.
Let's have a look at the manufacturing
sector.
In the bottom left hand corner, you can
see overall, we have a bearish number like
France and positively upward sloping
general trend.
But it's not as strong a sector as people
would have you believe or imagine if you
think of it in the context of the global
financial crisis.
And when you compare it to the service
sector.
So, for example, if you look at the GFC,
the global financial crisis recovery.
Yes, we do get a quick recovery in the
manufacturing sector 2010-11.
But then 2012, we go back into bearish
sentiment.
If you compare this to the service sector,
you can see sentiment in the service
sector in the financial crisis itself was
not as extreme in terms of sentiment.
And then the service sector recovered very
quickly and then stayed recovered in terms
of positive sentiment all the way up until
2020, which can't be the same can't be
said for the German manufacturing sector.
Which exhibited periods of negativity even
during the 2013-14-15 period.
So, the service sector was definitely
contributing more positively to the German
ESI than German manufacturing coming out
of the financial crisis.
Which would surprise many because in many
people's minds Germany is a big
manufacturing hub.
That's true.
So, the service sector is extremely strong
as well in Germany.
And it contributed way more positively to
the German recovery coming out of the
financial crisis of 2008-2009.
Also, when you look at services,
obviously, we note the long-term trend of
the red line, the long-term average trend
line going positive to way less positive
on average.
Now, if you look at consumers in the
bottom middle of the screen, German
consumers, again, like the French, they're
just always miserable.
It's just a matter of how miserable they
actually are.
Apart from a few positive blips, German
consumers are just generally always
bearish on their own sentiment.
So, we only really take note of the
long-term trend there and look at it from
the perspective in France and Germany as a
misery index.
We know they're miserable all the time.
It's just a question of how miserable they
are.
So, when we eyeball these things, we just
look at where we are.
Are we below long-term trend?
Are we above long-term trend?
Are we peaking?
Are we dropping?
Are we on our way to negative?
Are we recovering?
Are we just trying to put it into
perspective?
German retailers, another mess, another
disaster.
Pretty miserable picture there for German
retailers over the last 35 years.
Always bearish, generally, on average,
always reporting negative sentiment.
And German construction, apart from some
blips in the late 80s, early 90s, all
negative, apart from in recent history,
the 2016 to 2020 period.
And now, at the time of recording,
hovering around zero.
So, yes, above trend for the 2015 period
onwards, but looking tentative at the time
of recording.
Next up, Greece, the basket case of
Europe.
Not a big economy by any stretch, so we
don't pay much attention to it.
But any type of recovery in Greece, Greece
is very sensitive to the sentiment of the
future of the European project, the
Eurozone and the Euro currency.
We have to keep an eye on Greece a lot in
case there's any major turning points
there.
So, again, you just fill in your data,
eyeball the data on the charts.
Are we above trend?
Are we below trend?
Are we peaking?
Are we dropping?
Just good to keep on top of it.
Ireland, we don't spend too much time on.
Italy, third largest economy in Europe.
Eighth in the world, $2 trillion on 2019
numbers.
We do pay some attention to Italy, of
course.
We won't spend too much time on Italy
here.
Just eyeball the numbers.
The only bright spark for Italy has been a
move from negative sentiment on average
to, on average, positive sentiment over
the lifetime of the data for Italian
retailers.
So, when you think of the Italian retail
sector in the context of looking at their
own consumers, which are always bearish,
in the context of German and French
consumers, who are always miserable, it's
not a bad performance over a 35-year
period.
It's the only positive in the whole of
Italy.
If you look at manufacturing, if you look
at services, it's all a bit miserable over
a 35-year period.
Moving on to other areas within the
Eurozone.
Latvia, very small.
We don't pay much attention to.
We just fill in the data.
Same with Lithuania.
Luxembourg doesn't have data for services
and retail, but who really cares?
They're tiny.
Malta, tiny.
We don't pay much attention to.
Netherlands, a decent-sized economy.
We do pay some attention to it.
Portugal, decent-sized.
Slovak, Slovakia, Slovenia, we don't pay
much attention to.
And then we come to Spain, which we do pay
some attention to.
So, Spain, decent-sized economy, ranked
number 13th in the world on 2019 numbers
at $1.4 trillion.
If we look at the manufacturing sector,
generally always negative in Spain over
the lifetime of the data.
Services exhibiting similar to all the
other major economies, going from positive
sentiment to negative on average over the
data set.
Consumers, again, generally always
miserable.
Retailers, similar to Italy, not bad
considering the backdrop of consumer
sentiment within the Eurozone.
And we have that period in the 2013 to
2020, 2019, 2020 period, where we actually
had positive sentiment for quite a while
in Spanish retailers.
And the slope, our long-term moving
average is going higher.
Construction, you can see coming out of
the global financial crisis.
Well, you can see going into it
beforehand, actually, there was positive
sentiment for a very long period.
So, from the mid-90s all the way up to
beginning of the global financial crisis.
Apart from a few negative blips in
sentiment in the early 2000s, we had
positive sentiment for that whole period.
So, there was a massive boom in Spanish
construction, particularly in residential
housing.
And then the global financial crisis
occurred and they haven't recovered in
terms of sentiment ever since.
So, the downloadable spreadsheet, guys,
always updated every month.
Understand the global macro picture.
Always important to obviously not only
understand US GDP and trying to forecast
it with direction and growth, but also to
have an appreciation and understanding of
what's happening in the Eurozone as well.
Not least, because you can actually get
trade ideas from the Eurozone.
So, country ETFs are actually available as
tradable instruments in the United States,
denominated in US dollars.
And what we've done here is we've split up
Eurozone ETFs that are in the top 25 of
world GDP and ETFs that are outside the
top 25 of world GDP.
Let's start with Germany ranked fourth
largest economy in the world at 3.8
trillion.
Their ETF is the EWG ranked seventh France
at 2.7 trillion.
Their ETF is the EWQ.
Italy, EWI.
Spain, EWP.
And the Netherlands, EWN.
And on all of those products, you can
actually trade options as tradable
instruments.
So, call and put options on the actual
underlying products, the ETFs.
Countries that are in the Eurozone, but
they're not in the top 25 of world GDP.
These ETFs, in general, are a lot less
liquid than the five that we just looked
at that are in the top 25 of world GDP.
So, Austria, the EWO, you can trade the
ETF, but options are not available.
Belgium, options are actually available
for the Belgium ETF.
Finland, options are not available.
Greece actually has options available.
Ireland, not available.
And Portugal, unfortunately, not
available.
But it just means in places where you
don't have options available, you're just
forced to trade the underlying product,
the ETF itself.
So, you can't get much more leveraged
positions on for the directional bias that
you have for these countries.
Where you've got options available,
obviously, you can have leveraged bets on
the underlying products and the upside can
be quite large if you have a look at this
in detail.
But saying that, guys, this is not our
bread and butter in terms of what we do as
traders.
This is just optionality that increases
our opportunity set and may increase
diversity in our portfolios at any moment
in time in the future.
So, our focus as long-short equity
portfolio managers is to be looking at
stocks, getting a directional bias first
from our macro and then in our portfolios.
So, we get our directional bias and then
we're utilizing stocks in the stock
market, not necessarily macro bets, but
macro bets can occasionally be put on in
your portfolio.
As long-short equity portfolio managers,
our focus is stocks and we're combining
top-down analysis, macro analysis with
bottom-up analysis.
So, first and foremost, as traders and
PMs, we are seeking to utilize the macro
survey data to enable us to gauge which
way the wind is blowing so we can predict
GDP growth, index direction and potential
returns from the index and therefore our
portfolio bias.
So, with the ESI, the European Economic
Sentiment Indicator, we can obviously also
use the data to ascertain which countries
within the Eurozone are having the largest
magnitude moves and which areas of their
economies are actually having the largest
moves.
And when we do our monthly updates and we
organize our data, we can then potentially
generate country ETF and single stock
trade ideas to diversify our portfolios
and take positions in the country ETFs or
in European ADRs that are listed on the
New York Stock Exchange and NASDAQ.
But there is a caveat here to the stock
trades, for example, we would still have
to go through all the same processes that
we've covered in the IPLT video series to
determine suitability for stock ideas.
And any ideas that we're thinking of
putting on, we must go through the full
trade idea generation process of the PTM
video series.
Now, as you saw when we went through all
of the countries in the Eurozone, a lot of
them are too small to care about.
So we can eliminate a lot of countries,
but just being too small.
And that leaves us with an opportunity set
of tradable instruments that are inside
Europe.
Now, we also have a single stock level
have to be careful when trading European
ADRs.
We have to be careful in the larger
economies in the Euro area that we don't
put two and two together and get five.
Many companies in Europe that trade as
ADRs on the New York Stock Exchange are
global businesses and don't just have
exposure to their own country and exposure
to the Euro area.
However, there is a positive from the
geographical and currency exposures of
companies' revenue and earnings for us as
traders and PMs when we're doing that type
of analysis.
Because the ESI, when we look at the data
and at any one point in time, may
determine that there's a slowdown or a
pickup in certain areas of the Eurozone,
especially the larger economies.
When we look at US stock trade ideas, for
example, companies in the US that are
listed in the US that have significant
specific exposure to Europe or specific
countries in Europe in both revenues and
profits, we can obviously generate ideas
there.
So it's a push-pull situation for us as
traders and PMs.
Yes, we have to look at US leading
indicators.
They are our main set of leading
indicators that we pay attention to.
But we also have to have an understanding
and appreciation of the Eurozone and the
global macro picture, not least for our
directional buyers, but also for single
stock trade ideas.
And there's many companies in the US that
have global revenue and global profit, and
we have to understand where slowdowns and
pickups are occurring outside the United
States because they may actually be
happening before the US has a turning
point or a trend.
Now, in terms of European stocks that
trade on the New York Stock Exchange or in
the US, there's a decent source.
And you can go to this source to have a
look at a list of all of the stocks that
trade as American depository receipts,
ADRs on the New York Stock Exchange and
NASDAQ.
And that is topforeignstocks.com.
But this is at the time of recording,
guys.
You know, you've got to be
self-sustainable and use the search
engines at any moment in time to search
for sources and get into that habit.
Data sources that we use as examples in
the PTM video series may change over time.
Just use your common sense and get used to
using your search terms in Google.
A lot of the listed ADRs have also got
options, listed options, which is great
for us, that are not available in Europe
in their Euro-denominated lines of stock
at their own domestic exchanges.
But please note, over-the-counter, OTC
ADRs will not be tradable on retail
brokerage platforms.
Now, this particular source,
topforeignstocks.com, conveniently also
has international ADRs listed by sector as
well.
So you can go into each sector and look at
all of the international ADRs, not just
Europe, but all international ADRs listed
by industry sector.
So that's very useful for us as traders
and portfolio managers as we're drilling
down and trying to generate international
stock trade ideas.
Now, we are very soon in the video series
going to be getting into the meat of how
you generate single stock trade ideas.
So don't worry about that. We'll get into
that very soon.
But using the ESI survey data regularly on
a monthly basis to generate ideas, you
need to be very organized in sourcing the
data and in your processes.
We always obviously want to be working
smart, not too hard and saving time.
So eliminating all the noise and getting
the information that matters and
interpreting it properly.
If you're organized, you can get very good
at these processes and get a very good
read very quickly on what is going on in
the Eurozone with the ESI data.
And in the downloads area, you'll notice
in the spreadsheet, we've actually
compiled a lot of data processes in the
downloads area, which will be of great
help.
So you have to look at the notes area in
the download, follow the notes and follow
the instructions and guide on how to
update your data on a regular basis.
You'll notice in the main download for the
ESI, we have a tab called the all
countries data tab.
This provides a heat map of bullish and
bearish sentiment across all of the
countries in not just the Eurozone, but
also the European Union.
And we've taken a screenshot here from
August 18 to the beginning of 2021.
So from previous videos, our area of times
of economic history that we looked at from
previous videos.
So the August 18 to August 19 period, and
also up to December 2020.
You can see what's happening to headline
European sentiment.
So if you look at the third column along,
you'll see EA, which is the Euro area.
And then you'll see all of the
contributory countries to the Eurozone and
the EU as well.
And it should be fairly obvious, well,
blindingly obvious, actually, what was
happening over those periods.
You can just see a general decline from a
green to yellow to red.
So from bullish to neutral to bearish
sentiment over the period.
And of particular note, for example, is
coming out of the COVID economic shutdown
crisis.
Europe overall has struggled to get back
into bullish sentiment.
You'll also notice a tab in there in the
file called the Movers tab.
This basically splits the five areas.
So manufacturing services, consumers,
retailers, and construction, and ranks
them by relativity.
So which ones are the most bullish in
descending order to the most bearish for
the last month.
So when you update your data, you'll be
able to do this as well.
So it takes the respondents in each
country and sector versus the previous
month and ranks them relative to each
other,
most bullish to most bearish in descending
order for the previous month and also
includes a heat map as well.
So you can use this data to search for
potential single stock trade ideas within
certain countries and use the ADRs as
trades to do so or potential positions to
do so.
But it does come with the caveat,
obviously, that you have to have gone
through the full trade idea generation
process that we're going to teach you in
the PTM video series.
We don't rank the Movers in this sheet and
then look at the data, for example, and
say, OK, well, Greek construction is
extremely positively sentiment relative to
all other countries.
Therefore, we're just going to buy any old
Greek construction stock in Europe and
close our eyes and hope for the best.
We don't do that. Obviously, there's a lot
more work to do.
But what it should do is spark potential
trade ideas.
Now, let's summarize the European Economic
Sentiment Indicator, the ESI.
It's vitally important to our outlook for
European GDP growth, Euro Stock 600
direction and forming a global macro view
on our portfolio bias.
So the ESI is a leading indicator that can
be used in conjunction with all of the US
leading indicators that we've looked at so
far in the video series in order to form a
global macro view, both in the absolute
and the relative.
So in the absolute global GDP growth and
in the relative U.S. versus European GDP
growth.
Now, zooming in to the harmonized Euro
area, so the single currency Euro area.
So zooming in on that ESI and focusing on
the larger economies is the key to
understanding what's driving our
expectations of both European GDP growth
and Euro Stock 600 returns.
Germany, France and Italy are the largest
economies, and these should always be our
focus when analyzing monthly ESI data.
Now, you should also not only use the ESI
in Europe, you should also remember to use
the ESI in conjunction with European money
market indicators.
We mentioned this before in the video
series, and you've got downloads in the
downloads area of video four for the EU.
We've got German bonds, French government
bonds and Italian government bonds.
And if you apply the same principles and
the same metrics that we looked at for
U.S. money markets.
So utilizing real rates analysis and yield
curve analysis and spreads, you're going
to get a fantastic overall picture of the
macroeconomic situation in the Euro zone.
So apply the same principles we applied to
U.S. debt.
So real rates and yield curve analysis and
spreads to Europe.
And of course, you can also apply the same
methodologies we discussed with U.S.
corporate bonds to European corporate
bonds.
However, do bear in mind that the European
corporate credit market is much smaller
than the U.S.
Now, similar to the way in which U.S.
leading indicators give us a good gauge on
what the Fed might be thinking.
In Europe, the ESI leading indicator also
tells us what we should expect from the
ECB in terms of likely policy response.
Whether it's preemptive or reactive is
always up for question at any one moment
in time.
But do bear in mind, the ECB is watching.
The ECB is looking at the same things that
you are looking at.
Now, the ESI is also great for generating
potential trade ideas in European stocks
that are either listed in Europe on their
domestic exchange or listed as ADRs on the
New York Stock Exchange or NASDAQ.
As institute traders or ITPM, we much
prefer expressing our European trade ideas
via American depository receipts, ADRs on
New York Stock Exchange or NASDAQ.
However, when you're generating these
ideas and potentially taking positions,
the ESI should not be misused and
misinterpreted as an instant trade idea in
a particular area.
This is one of the bad habits of retail
traders, jumping to conclusions and not
completing the groundwork, the necessary
work.
You still have to go through the entire
trade idea generation process.
And every idea has to stand up to the
scrutiny of the process that you're going
to be learning in the PTM video series.
So, similar to when we looked at US
leading indicators and the processes of
potentially getting trade ideas in single
stocks from US leading indicators, it's no
different in Europe.
The ESI simply provides clues and triggers
for us to look in certain areas.
It doesn't provide instant, long or short
ideas for our portfolios.
The ESI, like all other leading indicators
that give us sector data, sparks our
interest or potential interest in
potential areas, potential sectors and
industries that we might want to look at.
We can then start putting the pieces
together and finding single stock trade
ideas by going through all of our other
processes that you're going to be learning
in upcoming videos.
Most importantly, with the ESI, it tells
us which way the wind is blowing in
Europe, which helps us with our global
macro view and long short equities
portfolio bias.
But of course, we can look at the sector
data and we can find potential areas of
interest that spark a level of interest in
a particular area.
But then we have to go and do the work on
the actual stocks themselves.
OK, so that about wraps it up for the
European Economic Sentiment Indicator, the
ESI.
Next, we're going to move on to China, but
let's go back to the desk first for a
little recap on the European Economic
Sentiment Indicator.
OK, so that was the European Economic
Sentiment Indicator, the European ESI.
And as you can see, it's very similar to
our US leading indicators, that being the
ISM Manufacturing, the Non Manufacturing
Index, the UMCSI and Building Permits.
But it's all wrapped into one giant data
set covering Europe.
So as traders that are predominantly US
focused, how do we use it on a monthly
basis?
Well, firstly, it aids us in determining
global GDP growth.
Secondly, it also tells us where growth is
potentially coming from in the world or
indeed where there's a lack of growth or a
slowdown occurring in the world.
So is there growth coming from the US,
Europe, China?
Is there a lack of growth coming from one
of those regions?
Third, it also gives us potentially some
trade ideas in European ADRs listed in the
United States.
And yes, when we look at the next video in
China, when we look at Chinese leading
indicators, this is the same situation
there as well.
Because we have Chinese ADRs which are
tradable in the United States.
We'll be looking at those in the next
video.
So it's the same in Europe as for China.
We have ADRs listed for both regions in
the United States.
Now, it's worth mentioning at this stage
that at ITPM, we are predominantly trading
US stocks.
Why? Because it's the richest environment
for data and stocks.
So for our opportunity set and for us to
get consistent returns.
So 50% of our students, our retail traders
are based in the United States and they
have their trading accounts in the United
States.
And 50% are outside the United States.
But even though these trading accounts and
the people are located outside the United
States, their trading accounts are
denominated in US dollars.
And they are predominantly trading US
stocks.
So when we add Europe and China to our
potential opportunity set, what we're
doing is we are increasing our opportunity
set.
But only if we are trading them
denominated in US dollars in our trading
accounts and we're trading them as ADRs.
OK, so Europe and China increase our
opportunity set as long as we are trading
them as ADRs.
So we are at ITPM always trading stocks
that are denominated in US dollars.
So this is another reason why we stay on
top of European and China leading
indicators.
So now we're going to move on to China in
the next video and we're going to be
looking at leading indicators for the
Chinese economy.
Now we have to approach China with caution
because data can be very unreliable.
You're going to see in the next video why.
And we're also going to show you some
tools and analysis that help you determine
the feasibility of Chinese data.
It's a fun video to watch and experience.
OK, so after the next video, we will
actually be jumping straight into video
15.
And we're going to do a full recap of all
of our leading indicators and the process.
And then I'll see you back at the desk in
video 16.
Let's get into it.